Speaker 1: We have news of yet another one
of these tragic accidents. The Daily Beast is
reporting that another Vladimir Putin ally has
been found dead after, quote, suffocating on a
business trip from a, quote, stroke. Hmm. Another
top ally reports The Daily Beast of Russian
President Vladimir Putin has died this week, this
time of an alleged stroke while on a business
trip in the village of Ros Chino in Russia's Far
East region. Vladimir soon. Girkin, 68 years old,
was editor in chief of the Russian state
newspaper. According to the newspaper Sun,
Gorgon died suddenly after showing signs of
suffocation during the trip. All of these terms
are in quotes, even in the article, by the way,
quote, It happened absolutely suddenly, nothing
foreshadowed. We were in the village of Ras Geno.
We were driving. We were already making our way
towards Khabarovsk. We planned to get there in the
evening and from there to Moscow. All was good,
said his colleague, who accompanied him on the
business trip. According to Zakharov, some Girkin
fell unconscious minutes after suggesting their
group find a beautiful place for lunch. 3 minutes
later, Vladimir began to suffocate. We took him
out for fresh air. He was unconscious. Nothing
helped. The doctor who did the initial exam
said apparently it was a stroke, but this is
only the initial conclusion. Now, some of you may
be confused. Wait, why? Why did a Putin ally die?
I thought it was Putin antagonists and Putin
enemies who kept accidentally dying. Remember?
Two weeks ago, I told you about the guy who. These
are just tragic accidents. He was in the hospital
for treatment, for a serious illness, and he
just fell out the window at the hospital. Very,
very tragic accident. Now, that was an antagonist
of Putin. So here's what you have to understand.
There is a bit of both going on. The way
that this is believed to function is the
Putin antagonists are sometimes killed, but also
Putin allies that are suspected of jumping ship
or are suspected of moving in a disloyal way. They
also sometimes have to be taken out. And Wikipedia
actually maintains an article called 2022 Russian
Businessman Mystery Deaths. And you can just look
through this and see the list. And it is wild,
wild, wild, wild. And the list is quite long.
You might remember Reveal Magnus of he's the guy
I told you about who was reportedly hospitalized
for heart problems and depression and then, quote,
fell out of a window and was a big. Putin critic.
So as we've talked about before, many of you, when
we do these stories will react and say, David,
this stuff is so obvious. Like no one believes
that these are accidents or deaths from illness.
Why isn't Putin slicker in how he
does it? That's exactly the point.
As I've told you before, the whole point here is.
It's important that it be known that these stupid
explanations are just untrue. Stupid explanations.
That's the idea. That's how you sow fear. If it
was really believed that this was a stroke and
the other guy fell out the window or whatever,
then it wouldn't have the chilling effect that
it's meant to have. And so we're going to continue
tracking these. It's about, I believe, 20 or
20 to various oligarchs, allies and antagonists
who have died in just tragic accident, supposedly,
is what we're supposed to believe. We're going to
continue following that list and you can check out
that list on the wiki page, which we will link to.